I know that this road
has been very hard.
What's going on? And that ahead of you.
Something little b said
Dominic Toretto.
You're about to learn all about fear.
You’re not afraid of anything.
But I am afraid of losing someone I love.
you built such a beautiful life
filled with love and family.
I never got the chance.
My family.
You stole that from me
My future.
I'm going to break yours.
Piece by piece.
He's coming for you with everything.
One of us might not come back from this
What's the plan, Dom?
I'm not sure anymore.
But we have to fight.
Never accept death.
suffering is owed
It's a setup.
He's trying to tear us apart.
I got one when it used to be about winning
That's the problem
with having such a big family.
How do you choose the ones you save?
We raced for respect
together.
I raced to stop the bloodbath.
Let’s Race
It's showtime.
We go.
Game recognizes.
Game.
You still know how to drive
What do you think?
Coming for you, son
Here they come.
You will never be able to break my family
The morning
sunshine.
Welcome back, everyone.
They dropped the Fast and Furious
ten trailer.
Fast x,
a bunch of Easter eggs and references
going all the way back to the first movie.
So we'll break it all down.
See how many times
they're able to say family in the movie.
If you're brand new to the channel,
there's a whole bunch of Super Bowl
trailers coming this weekend.
Of course, I'll do videos for everything.
Be sure to subscribe to get them all.
The whole idea of this movie is
that it's not actually the last movie.
It's meant to be the beginning
of the end of the road.
As they say in the trailer.
They're actually pulling in Avengers
Infinity War and Avengers Endgame.
Originally
it was going to be the last movie,
but then they split it
into two different movies.
So technically
they'll be 11 in the mainline continuity.
Obviously, of the Hobbs
and Shaw spin offs,
but I don't think they're going
to be doing those movies anymore.
Pretty sure Vin Diesel and The Rock
are not on speaking terms anymore
during this movie,
though, as you can see in the trailer,
Jason
Momoa is meant to be the main villain.
He's playing a character called Dante.
He's meant to be the son of the drug
kingpin from Fast Five who they robbed
all the money from in that big action
scene, as you see in the trailers,
a lot of the trailer either
references or directly shows moments
from the previous movies.
So it's like they want to say
that the Dante character
has been orchestrating things
from behind the scenes,
pulling strings from behind the scenes
for the last four movies
or so after he recovered.
It sounds like what happened
is that during that
big bridge escape scene,
Dom and Brian almost wound up killing him.
He barely survived.
And then Suarez revenge using his father's
money to orchestrate this grand revenge
plan, eventually kidnaping his son,
little Brian, that he had with Elena.
And as he says in the trailer, that's
one of the things he's most afraid of,
most afraid of things
happening to my family.
Pretty much everybody, as you see in the
trailer, is back from the previous movies,
including Charlize Theron's
cipher villain in there.
A few new characters as well.
Like I said,
because this is meant to be the beginning
of the end, like the last two movies
or one movie split
into two different movies.
A lot of it is meant to wrap up
storylines that they haven't paid off
since the first movie in reference things
from every single movie.
Same thing
they did with Marvel Phase one, Phase two
and Phase three and Infinity War
in Avengers Endgame.
But because of the arc of a lot of fast
and Furious movies,
I would not be surprised
if Jason Momoa's character winds up
turning good at the end of the movie,
because that's kind of the theme
with most of the villains.
With the exception
of Charlize Theron character,
she's been one of the few characters
who has been straight up villain in
pretty much all the movies she's been in.
Although to make another Marvel joke,
Vin Diesel
did joke about having Robert Downey
Jr star in the next movie,
like the actual final movie
as the anti Dom and he be a character
hyping up all this driverless technology
and it'd be like the opposite of what Dom
would want Pretty sure Robert Downey
Jr not going to sign up for Fast
and Furious movie,
but it is funny to think about that.
You starting
at the beginning of the trailer footage,
the first big thing here is that Rita
moreno is going to be playing
their grandmother.
Typically in these movies
they try to cast the biggest person
you can think of to be either
their mothers or their grandmothers.
Getting someone like Helen Mirren to play
Shaw's mother is a good example
that this is Ladies
Chevy from the previous movies.
There's a bunch of their cards from the
previous movies all across the trailer.
This picture is actually taken
from Fast Forward, like the fourth movie
that was sort of the reboot
of the franchise and that's Brian's rex.
In the background, we see a much older
version of Little Brian.
He's still very, very little.
The funny thing about Elena
is they actually developed her
as a love interest for Vin Diesel
when Letty wasn't
going to be a part of the franchise,
that whatever problems
they had behind the scenes,
they worked those out,
then brought her back to the movies.
So that's why they probably killed
Elena off.
You actually see footage that goes back
to the second movie, two Fast two Furious.
That's what I say when
I mean the referencing things
from all the previous movies,
even though it sounds like Dante
didn't know them until the fifth movie.
You see him on a flat track.
Harley going to get revenge
on one of the crew members
planting a bomb on one of their cars.
This scene of the other motorcycle
riding by him is Letty.
She looks like she gets into a wreck.
Roman comes back, meets with Tash in Fords
with Ramsay.
Rio is where the fifth movie took place,
where he's supposed to have met
Jason Momoa's character
for the first time.
This looks like it's from the fifth movie,
right after they stole the safe.
He says, You stole that for me.
My future,
my family,
as they literally stole the money
and wound up
leading to his father's death,
even though his father was a drug kingpin,
doing really terrible stuff.
Not sure where he is in this scene.
It just looks like he's with his crew
plotting some more of his revenge plan.
It seems like there's a lot of tech here,
so he might have some connection
with Seyfried's villain character,
because if he really has been behind
the scenes
orchestrating things
for the past couple of movies,
he would have to have been connected
to Cipher in some way.
He might have just been bankrolling
a lot of her plan.
We meet Brie Larson's test character.
It seems like she has some
preexisting relationship with Dom and
it seems like she's trying to help them.
But in another scene,
she's wearing the suit. She's all buttoned
down, different haircut,
one of them might be a flashback scene.
She could be working against the crew
at some point.
There's a lot of scenes where it's
hard to tell
if it's a flashback and they're trying to
recontextualize events of previous movies
or if it's in present day in.
They've switched sides.
It looks like Jason Momoa's
crew breaks into Dom's house
and orchestrates this big kidnaping,
and that's how they get little Brian.
John Cena comes back as Jacob Toretto,
his younger brother.
He's one of the good characters now.
Like he turned sides
at the end of the last movie.
This is a scene of Han driving a new car
and Alpha Gt4, which is a European car.
Even after he came back
in the previous movies,
he still drove some of his previous cars
for a while.
Speaking of justice for Horn,
they actually pay off the moment.
They kind of tease
that in the previous movie
we get another moment with Shaw in Horn
reuniting with each other.
But since their previous run in the third
movie, Shaw has turned good
and now they sort of
have to reckon with that.
And Shaw is trying to atone
for a lot of the crazy stuff that he did.
It sounds like they'll throw it out
a little bit
and then they'll eventually make peace,
like they'll be cool with it by the end.
There's a couple different street races
I can't tell
if these are all from the same scenes or
some of these are meant to be flashbacks
because you have Dom in the crew
racing against Jason Momoa's
Dante character and some of his crew,
and it sounds like that might happen
in a couple of these different movies,
like they're recontextualizing their run
ins in previous films.
There's a couple of big bridge
fight scenes too.
I think these bigger bridge fights are
a reference back to Fast and Furious six
and then whatever's going on
in this laboratory, this medical facility
here, Charlize Theron's cipher character
comes back and throws down with Letty.
Like I said, the arc of all Fast
and Furious villains, or that
at some point they joined the crew, like
they all turned good, enjoying the crew.
So we'll see what happens with her
cipher character.
I don't know if they want to use her
is like the ultimate big bad
for all the movies or if she will
turn good in the final movie.
Either way, I cannot wait to see
Jason Momoa Throwdown with Vin Diesel
and then just go at each other
the way the Jason
Momoa talked about his character.
He's meant to be like the anti Dom, like
totally over-the-top, super flamboyant,
as opposed to Dom who's way more reserved
and quiet during the trailer.
You see a couple of moments
where he's kind of throw that in his face,
like, look at the way that Jason Momoa is
dressed.
Like,
how much over-the-top could you get here?
This is the campy as thing ever.
If you spotted any of their Easter eggs
or references
to the previous Fast
and Furious movies in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
They'll be a whole bunch more footage for
this before the movie comes out in May.
We get a bunch more Super Bowl trailers.
I'll do videos for everything.
Make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss those.
I think the next big one
will be the flash trailer
and then after that will be
a couple of big Marvel trailers.
I'll try to post everything
as quickly as possible.
It'll protect me in the next
couple of days to get through everything.
Everyone click here
for the new Flash trailer.
I'll update the link as soon as I finish
posting that and click here
for my new Loki Season two trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.